I'll have to tell you guys I think this
is perhaps the greatest failure of
Trump's presidency he has on this issue
shown and almost bewildering lack of of
leadership and frankly even interest
when Eric's well well farted the whole
night past much like the gas passed from
swallow well and Trump said nothing
issued no tweet okay and then the next
day comes still nothing we've got a
Democrat farting on live TV Donald Trump
somehow for some reason says nothing
about it at all
and as if that wasn't bad enough this
morning Trump tweeted about SWA well we
finally got the swell well tweet I saw
Trump's Twitter soir well I'm thinking
now it's finally here still didn't
mention it this morning Trump tweeted
this is what he said why do shannon
bream and fox news waste airtime a
Democrat representing X well well who
recently left the presidential primaries
having attained a grand number of zero
in the polls I don't even know how that
is possible Fox should stay with the
people that got them they're not losers
come on he he even says wastes airtime
but then doesn't throw in a thing about
the fart all you needed was something in
the parentheses about the fart and this
is a this is like criticizing this is
like if Trump was criticizing OJ and
didn't mention the fact that he killed
two people or criticizing you know John
Travolta and didn't mention Battlefield
Earth and just I know it's obvious but
at the same time you can't leave that
out what did we elect Donald Trump for
if he's not going to tweet about
swaddles farts I thought we'd easily
have fifteen or twenty tweets by now how
is it the the moment that happened they
should have been in the Oval they should
have been in the war room coming up with
a strategy how was he not giving an
address to the nation from the Rose
Garden the next day about this I could
tell you one thing what I am president I
promise you that if one of my opponents
farts on live TV they will be the only
thing I talk about for the next month I
will give a in address to a joint
session of Congress about it I won't let
you down the way the Trump has led us
down
stand aside that something's going on
here with Trump
now I'm gonna get to the bottom of it so
to speak
anyway debate last night so Democrat
debate another one halfway through yeah
I checked halfway through the debate I
checked online just to see how many of
these things we've got coming up still
and they're gonna do seven more they've
got seven more of these debates coming
up but they get progressively more
boring with each one although I was
pretty upset last night because I'm
watching it I'm gritting my teeth
getting through it using all my
willpower a heroic effort if I must say
especially because before the debate I'm
thinking okay I got to do some debate
prep because I got to watch this thing I
go to the liquor cabinet I realize I'm
out of bourbon now me running out of
bourbon is unheard of I don't know how
that's in doesn't oversight already but
running out of bourbon before a debate
that I was ashamed by that embarrassed
and then I had to go through the entire
debate without it so finally about I
don't know maybe about hour and fifteen
minutes into it I give up can't take it
anymore
almost bored bored to death literally
literally almost bored to death on the
verge of cardiac arrest so I turned the
TV off and apparently it was it was
right when I turned it off that joe
biden said blacken american right when i
turn it off
this is i paid my dues I watched it for
four seventy five minutes I put my time
in I deserve to see that live what had
happened I deserve the reward of hearing
Joe Biden live say black freaking
American those are the moments we long
for when we're watching these debates
and and I missed it but I suppose this
is why God made YouTube thankfully so we
can we can relive it and actually
Biden's entire answer on race was was
pretty great watch this
I you know I'm part of that that Obama
coalition I come out of the black
community in terms of my support if you
notice I have more people supporting me
in the
black community that announced for me
because they know me they know who I am
three former chairs of the Black Caucus
the only black American woman that ever
been elected to the United States Senate
a whole range of people
years
to be vice president was because of my
relationship long-standing relationship
with the black community black frickin
American I you could tell that he was he
was going in with black right and then
he realized that the more halfway
through saying black he realized the
more PC thing as african-american so
then he tries to change but you can't if
you've already started with black you
just have to commit you can't you can't
switch midstream and that's that's just
a good general rule of thumb when you're
talking about races and ethnicities if
you're going with one thing don't switch
so it's like if you if you started to
say Hispanic and then you realize
halfway through that Latino is the more
popular thing to say these days you
can't try to switch because then it's
going to come out as his Tino and then
what you've done is you've made up a new
term for a race and or an ethnicity and
I think this is again general rule of
thumb as a politician is a you don't
want to come up with new terms for races
and ethnicities you really want to stick
with the established ones you don't want
to accidentally make up a new one that's
that is that's a rookie mistake that Joe
Biden made at the age of 78 and then the
interesting thing is that Joe Biden
claims to have come out of the blue a
freaking American community
which I guess he's saying that he is
black or IIIi don't know it just
profoundly awkward all around you've got
this old white guy talking about the
black in American community just trying
to trying to claim that he's got the
most support among black people out of
anyone on the stage talking about his
credentials on race then you got the
split screen with an actual black man
listening to him and it's really awkward
in fact all of Joe Biden's answers
become 50 times more awkward if we get
the split screen of someone reacting to
what he's saying in real time doesn't
matter what he's saying it's just it's
always because the reaction from the
other person whether it's another
candidate somebody in the audience
you're cut your expression is always
when you're listening to Joe Biden and
give an answer you're kind of always
like yeah it's you got this expressed
kind of the expression that you have
when you're watching football and
somebody's knee bends the wrong way and
you're just like that and that's that's
the expression every time Joe Biden
starts to talk very painful very painful
very painful moment or Joe meant as he
might say Joe Biden was also asked about
domestic violence now this should be a
layup okay you be
a chance to talk about why domestic
violence is bad you can't ask for more
of a softball than that as a politician
but this is Joe Biden we're talking
about and here's the interesting thing
that I've noticed this and this is kind
of a formula and equation with Joe Biden
doesn't hold up every single time but
sometimes he just dives right in with
the crazy like he did with like he did
with Blair akin American but generally
I've noticed that he can give kind of a
good at least decent passable answer for
60 seconds 60 seconds is Joe Biden's
cutoff he could talk about something
usually for 60 seconds and everything
would be basically fine once he goes
over that 60 second marker that's when
he hits a landmine and everything falls
apart
I'll show you what I mean so let's watch
here's his answer our domestic violence
let's watch the first 60 seconds and and
then we'll go to the next but here's the
first 60 seconds of his answer yes and
by the way it's one of the reasons the
first thing I would do is make sure we
passed the Violence Against Women Act
reauthorization which I wrote in fact I
didn't write the reauthorization I wrote
the original Act the fact is that what
happens now is that we in fact have to
fundamentally change the culture the
culture of how women are treated that's
why as vice-president when I asked the
president I could start the the movement
on the college campuses to say it's on
us it's everyone's responsibility we do
not spend nearly enough time dealing
with I was stunned when I did a virtual
town meeting that told me 30,000 people
are on the on the call young people
between 15 and 25 and found out I said
what do you need what you need to make
you safer on college campuses on your
schools you know what they said get men
involved engage the rest of the
community and that's what we started
this movement on the college campuses to
fundamentally change the culture okay so
that's fine right pretty good no problem
not great but passable he'll get by but
the witching hour hits the clock strikes
60 Joe Biden turns into a pumpkin and
this is the pivot point okay he's on the
right path saying the right thing but
then he gets to a rhetorical fork in the
road and one path points to normal one
path is sort of normal wrap it up
you're done the other path points to
crazy nonsense like he sees a sign you
know arrow crazy nonsense this way
normal that way and for some reason he's
already been on the path of 60 seconds
and he says well I guess I'll just go
with the crazy nonsense and he goes down
that path so let's watch the pivot the
change of direction and everything falls
gloriously to pieces no man has a right
to raise a hand to a woman in anger
other than in self-defense and that's
rarely ever occurs and so we have to
just change the culture period and keep
punching at it and punching at it and
punching that it will be a big it's a
gigantic issue and we have to make it
clear from the top from the President on
down that we will not tolerate it we
will not tolerate this culture
now before we analyze what we all just
heard there look at Joe's expression at
1:33 in that clip we just show that the
freeze-frame 1:33 that's the expression
of somebody who knows that and then
that's right after he was done talking
and he knows that he just said some
crazy crap he knows it that's him in his
head going oh no why did I just did I
just start did I just say punching at it
did I just say that that was a mistake
that was a mistake the pivot point here
was when he started stipulating the
circumstances when it would be okay to
hit a woman that's when now we're now
we're off the rails then he's right of
course it is it is okay to hit a woman
in self-defense I think obviously right
it's does anyone think that that a woman
has some sort of mystical rights to just
beat the crap out of whoever they want
without ever without anyone ever
defending themselves of course he's
correct in saying that but
just in terms of optics in terms of
politics it's not a great idea to get
into that there's no reason to you
weren't asked about that the question
wasn't when he said okay to hit a woman
that would not be a question I would
expect to hear in an MSNBC debate so
he's talking about domestic violence he
doesn't start neat he doesn't need to
start listing scenarios where it might
be okay to hit a woman he doesn't need
to go listen it's never okay to hit a
woman but if she knows karate and she's
trying to kill your dog then it's just
don't don't go there and you know that
all of his handlers and all of Joe's
people they're backstage watching this
and they hear him go no man has a right
to hit a woman and they're thinking to
themselves okay just stop there Joe end
of sentence move on to the next thought
move on to the next thought and then he
continues on that thought and they're
thinking oh my oh god no no no and it's
off the rails all is law so he starts
babbling about punching punching
punching at it he's talking about
domestic violence like we need to punch
at the problem I in and I feel bad for
the audience because every time the
audio biden's audience I always feel bad
for them because they don't know how to
react to what he's saying and you know
we've all been in this and this this
situation we all have relatives like
this like you're sitting around at
Thanksgiving there's always that
relative that says a bunch of awkward
stuff and you never know if they're
being stupid on purpose or if they're
trying to make a joke or if they're
being serious then so you don't know if
you're supposed to laugh or not and so
there's always this awkward half laugh
half serious thing and that's Joe
Biden's audience all the time because
they hear him saying this and they're
thinking is it is this a is he doing
this on purpose is he making a domestic
violence joke what am I supposed to
react to this I would I would hate to
hear Joe Biden asked in fact never mind
I would love to hear him asked about
what to do about the murder rate
listen with the murder rate
we just need a stab at it need to keep
stabbing shoot it
gouge out its eyes choke it
buried in the forest that's what we got
to do about the murder rate this guy's
the Democratic frontrunner the
Democratic Party has lost its will to
live if this is if they nominate this
guy they just have given up I think the
Democrat Party they they have given up
Trump has officially broken them
irrevocably and this is it they've just
that's that's a white flag when they
when they put up Joe Biden they're
saying all right forget it we don't even
care anymore okay a few other things
from the debate to discuss but first a
word from Rock auto
different price tiers for professional
mechanics and do-it-yourselfers
rockauto.com prices though are the same
for everybody and they're reliably low
for everybody that's the best part Rocko
com always offers the lowest prices
possible rather than changing prices
based on what the market will bear kind
of like airlines do and do a lot of
traveling not a fan of that but
rockauto.com it's for everybody
it's cheap affordable for everybody
doesn't require membership doesn't
require a count log in and it's just
it's really easy to navigate
rockauto.com is a family business
serving Auto Parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com shop for
auto embody parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they have everything from
engine control modules brake parts tail
lamps motor oil new carpet if you need
it so whether it's your classic or daily
driver whatever it is that you have you
can get everything you need a few easy
clicks delivered directly to your door
and that's this for me that's the thing
I like to emphasize about rockauto.com
is just how simple and easy it is a lot
a lot simpler and easier than you know
having to get in your car go to the
actual store and you're to spend more
money or spend more time better just go
and rockauto.com amazing selection
reliably low prices all the parts your
call will ever need rockauto.com go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck right
walsh
in there how did you hear about us box
so that they know that we sent you
that's rockauto.com
okay uh what else well you know I loved
Camela Harris here there's one Camille
Harris moment I like she's here she is
bragging about losing listen to this I
believe we have to have the ability to
not only have a nominee who can go
toe-to-toe with Donald Trump and I have
taken on Jeff session I've taken on Bill
Barr I have taken on Brett Kavanaugh I
know I have the ability to do that okay
all those people she just bragged about
that those people were confirmed
so she says she took that she took them
on and lost I took them on yet you lost
though this is me this would be like the
head coach of the bangles trying to keep
his job and talking to the owner and
saying hey listen I took on the 49ers I
took on the Seahawks I took on the
Ravens and the Rams yeah but you lost by
a combined 6,000 points so it doesn't
really I mean the fact that you took
them on and lost is sort of the point
here but it's nice that Camille is proud
of losing because of course she's gonna
do it again in the primary so the fact
that she enjoys it and takes pride in it
I guess is is good for her I feel and
I'm glad that she's made peace with it
and so I feel a little bit better about
that as well okay now here's Bernie
giving the earth a new prognosis I
thought we had 12 years to live I think
this is kind of a headline apparently we
only have eight or nine years to live
listen listen to Bernie giving us the
bad news now I disagree with the thrust
of the original question your question
has said what are we gonna do in decades
we don't have decades what the
scientists are telling us we don't get
our act together within the next eight
or nine years we're talking about cities
all over the world major cities going on
the water we're talking about increased
Prout talking about increased extreme
weather disturbances the United Nations
is telling us that in the years to come
they're going to be hundreds of millions
of climate refugees causing massive
national security issues all over the
world
that's why well fart was worse than I
thought shaved four years off the life
span of the earth
I mean he's literally killing us and
still Trump didn't say anything about it
well I'm not gonna get back into that
and then we get to Warren and as always
from Warren we've got a vile propaganda
and lies that's her sort of her thing
it's her favorite thing to do both of
those and so let's start with her sales
pitch for abortion listen I believe that
abortion rights are human rights I
believe that they are also economic
rights and protecting the right of a
woman to be able to make decisions about
her own body is fundamentally what we do
and what we stand for as a democratic
party understand this when someone makes
abortion illegal in America rich women
will still get abortions it's just gonna
fall hard on poor women it's gonna fall
hard on girls women who don't even know
that they're pregnant because they have
been molested by an uncle I want to be
an America where everybody has a chance
yes in America
where everybody has a chance you give
everyone a chip every person a chance by
killing millions of persons this is
actually an important point because the
idea behind abortion is expressly
explicitly not to give everyone a chance
that's the point
it is to prioritize certain people over
other people okay it's to give the older
generation a chance by destroying the
younger by giving the younger generation
no chance it's to give parents a chance
by allowing them to execute their
children that's the whole point the
point of the pro-life movement is to
give everyone a chance that's our thing
that's our argument our objective that's
what we're trying to do where the give
everyone a chance side but the other
side you're the you're the you know
establishing hierarchies and competing
claims to rights and weighing this
against that and you know favoring this
so this person over that person that's
your thing that's what you do on the
pro-abortion side this is how it goes
the pro-abortion side is so wrong soda
based so evil so irrational so that it
has to use our arguments and pretend
that it's making our case it borrows our
rhetoric our arguments because it knows
that we are arguing for something that
is clearly more moral and and more just
and so it has to pretend basically as to
basically the pro-abortion side pretends
that it's arguing our case so that was
Warren misdirecting and misleading now
let's take a look at her just straight
up bald-faced lying
you have cast yourself as a fighter if
you were elected though you would be
walking into an existing fight a country
that is already very divided over the
trump presidency among other things do
you see that divide as permanent or do
you need to bring the country together
if you become president to achieve your
goals so I think the way we achieve our
goals and bring our country together as
we talk about the things that unite us
and that is that we want to build an
America that works for the people not
one it just works for rich folks you
know I have proposed a two-cent wealth
tax that is a tax for everybody who has
more than 50 billion dollars in assets
your first 50 billion is free and clear
250 billion that first dollar you got a
pitch in two cents and when you hit a
billion dollars you got a pitch in a few
pennies more here's the thing doing a
wealth tax is not about punishing anyone
it's about saying you built something
great in this country good for you but
you did it using workers all of us help
pay to educate you did it using you're
getting your goods to run on roads and
bridges all of us help pay for it did it
protected by police and firefighters all
of us help pay the salaries for so when
you make it big when you make it really
big when you make a top one-tenth of 1%
big pitch in two cents so everybody else
gets a chance to make it even here's the
thing that's something that Democrats
care about independents care about and
Republicans care about because
regardless of party affiliation people
understand across this country our
government is working better and better
for the billionaire's for the rich for
the well-connected and worse and worse
for everyone else we come together when
we acknowledge that in Sangamon real
changes okay so she says that she'll
that her wealth tax would for the first
50 million would tax people not at all
the first 50 million is free and clear
she says and then once you hit 50
million you've got to pitch in a couple
pennies she says you have to pay two
cents
Peet's this this several times in the
debate millionaires and billionaires are
packed taxed two cents two pennies
couple pennies and with those pennies
she's gonna pay for universal pre-k free
college pay raises for daycare workers
debt forgiveness several other things
all with the pennies from billionaires
and there are what like six hundred
billionaires in America so two pennies
from each of them so so basically she's
gonna do all this with twelve dollars
she's got twelve bucks and she's gonna
take care of all those problems that now
that's a good deal
listen I I support that if you could
just if you could do all that with
twelve bucks then sure go ahead
but of course the problem is that it's
all why she's not she's not talking well
she can't and won't do all the things
she's promising to do in terms of all
the things she's gonna pay for but she's
also not talking about a two cent tax
she's talking about a two percent tax so
I know I know it's a difference of only
three letters sent percent PR you know
but it's a significant difference
actually in terms of numbers and
actually for billionaires her latest
plan is more like six percent which
would equal sixty million dollars or if
you want to talk about it in terms of
pennies it would be what's six hundred
billion pennies so you know just throw
in six hundred billion pennies not two
pennies six hundred billion pennies
that's the that's a difference of only
about well six hundred billion pennies
approximately but even that doesn't
quite capture it because actually her
wealth tax is way more extensive way
further reaching way costlier than two
or even six percent a piece at the Tax
Foundation tax foundation.org talks
about this Amanda has a piece on The
Daily wire talking about this going into
more detail and go read those pieces
suffice it to say that Warren's plan is
much much much more involved than how
she portrays it and and that's just
that's just as the plan currently stands
and that's trusting that the taxes won't
go up won't go up overtime but of course
they will
I mean her plan her taxes have already
gone up and she and she's not even
elected yet but when they're enacted
then we know that it expands from there
one thing we've learned is the
government never gives money back they
never give up power
they've already seized they never relent
they never pull their hand out of your
pocket just like the income tax was
originally supposed to be moderate and
temporary and now look at us that's the
way it always works and Warren knows it
and this is just the first step step
number one and it is despite how she
tries to frame it it's a very
significant step already but it's not
even the last step by a longshot and of
course she uses the old we paid for the
roads stick to justify it which I guess
there are a lot of people in America
dumb enough to buy into that line
otherwise I should probably stop saying
it so it's just which first of all if
we're talking about loan forgiveness for
example recent college graduates
actually haven't paid for anything they
haven't contributed to the roads they
haven't paid for the roads they haven't
paid to educate workers or anything else
the the contributions of a person in
their early to mid 20s who just got out
of college their contributions
economically in terms of taxes are
exceedingly negligible so the idea that
an adult who's worked for decades built
up his wealth somehow owes this kid
money because of the kids contribution
to road maintenance how much has he
chipped it he's probably actually
literally chipped in two cents now
you've got two cents short so you've got
you know a successful businessman who's
already paid millions upon millions in
taxes he's the one building the roads
and paying for all this stuff and then
you got a kid that's 23 years old at a
college got his first job
what you're saying that the the million
arrows that kid because of the kids cut
what is he contributed to nothing and
even if he had the idea that because we
all chip in to pay for the roads which
isn't example as I make it sound but
even still the idea that okay we all pay
taxes for the roads and therefore if you
use the road then all of your money
belongs to everybody what kind of
nonsense is that and people find that
convincing really that's compelling come
on
all right before we move on you know if
you haven't been listening to Andrew
clavin's fantasy podcast and other
Kingdom then you need to get your life
together first of all you need to go to
daily wired.com subscribe right now to
catch up because on Monday November 25th
at 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific Andrew
and Michael Knowles will be sitting down
together to discuss the final season and
also take subscriber questions live from
the fans this live event will be free
for everyone to watch on Facebook and
YouTube but only subscribers will be
able to ask questions so you got to go
to daily wired.com Plus subscribers
exclusively can watch the entirety of
this series or you can listen free to
the newest seasons on the apple podcast
go check it out don't miss the the
another Kingdom live discussion
happening Monday at 7 p.m. Eastern 4
p.m. Pacific have you guys seen these
trailers for the cats movie we just play
this real quick they're making a movie
based on the musical Cats for some
reason I don't know if you've seen these
things we'll watch this tonight is a
magical night
where I choose the cat it deserves a new
life going to the ball could get
dangerous
[Music]
I've got a cat bite so
I've got plenty of soul
spotlight and a drumroll please
[Applause]
his party time
the most deserving cat will be reborn
into another life
so they can be who they've always
dreamed to be that looks that looks
horrified doesn't it then they look
terrifying honestly a musical where
everyone it's okay so you've got a
musical number one that's strike number
one and everybody's dressed like a cat
that's basically my cinematic worst-case
scenario that's I couldn't think of a
worse thing you could not think of a
less appealing storyline for me than
that I'd rather watch Texas Chainsaw
Massacre in 3d where Leatherface
actually comes out of the screen and
pails me on a meat hook and skins me
alive I would take that experience over
over this and think about the fact that
this dreck this garbage
the green light how many interesting
thoughtful original scripts were thrown
in the recycle bin so that the studio
could dump resources into this ode to
furries think about that that's that's
what's the pressing all right I want to
moving on to something more part I want
to revisit this issue briefly I'm not
I'm not because I'm not looking to just
move past it after talking about it one
time as we discussed yesterday the
school board over at of district 2 at
district 211 in Illinois voted last week
fighted to decision to allow biological
males into the female locker room a
Palin teen Palatine High School in
Illinois and the board said that all
students should be quote treated and
supported in a manner consistent with
their gender identity this support
apparently necessitates obliterating the
privacy and safety and security of every
girl at the school a student named Nova
Mayday
a biological male identifies as
transgender filed a lawsuit in 2017
against the school the lawsuit came
after a Department of Education mandate
in 2015 under Obama forcing Palatine
high school to allow boys like himself
into the bathrooms and locker rooms with
girls but the school tried to come up
with a compromise and they said ok yo
you can come into the girls room but
we're gonna have private stalls set up
for you and you go right into the stalls
and that's where you get changed and do
your business and then you leave ok you
don't have to change with the boys then
if that makes you feel so big you know
if that if that makes you so upset
but Maday was not happy with this time
wise he demanded that he has access not
just to the girls locker room but to the
exact same area where the girls change
to be clear that's what this is really
about it's not about access to the
locker room he already got that but now
he wants to be in the same area in the
same exact room and space where girls
are changing his basic human rights are
evidently violated if he's not able to
actually see girls get naked and himself
get naked in front of them that's what
he's claiming he has a human rights he
has a human right here's a human right
to see girls get naked to get naked in
front that's what he say the school
board found these deranged arguments
convincing and now as we discussed
yesterday every girl in school must shut
up and cooperate as biological males
invade their private spaces now if you
need any help understanding why this is
crazy and and and why this is just evil
really there's a video I played it
yesterday that was recorded by the Daily
Herald a herald reporter interviewed
Maday after the school board vote then
also interviewed another girl named
Julia and so you see that another girl I
interviewed Maday who's a boy and then
interviewed Julia who's an actual girl
not another girl she's the only girl
interviewed between the two of them just
to be clear but anyway the contrast
between their two reactions is stark you
got mad a sporting a queen shirt and
long pink hair celebrating the decision
says he's ecstatic says it's a great
step for it of course he's not satisfied
though cuz he still said he still
complains that didn't go quite far
enough
he says it's you know it's not
everything we wanted because it's it's
just like what we've been talking about
chick-fil-a this week it's never
everything they want it's never enough
never ever enough he got everything he
wanted but it's not everything he wanted
and then the tenor changes dramatically
with Julia's reaction her voice is
shaking their tears in her eyes she says
she was uncomfortable you know her
privacy is being invaded she talks about
how she's a swimmer so she gets changed
multiple times throughout the day
completely changed no she's getting into
a bathing suit out of the bathing suit
right and she's doing this in full view
of the other students in the locker room
which is fine when their girl
but she's saying she's really
uncomfortable with a boy being involved
in that and and yet yet what I thought
was striking about the video one of the
striking things is that even in the face
of this outrageous trampling of her
basic privacy rights
she still attempts to be as generous as
possible to Maday and and you know that
side of the discussion by saying that
well look I understand the school has an
obligation to all students but I just I
think I should be accommodated too now I
don't think the school board or mad a or
the trans activists pushing this crap
deserve even the slight concession she
offers them and and in the generosity
and and and grace that she extends I
think she deserves a lot of credit for
that she's more mature than I am because
I wouldn't be to be so graceful about it
but my point is that you see the
contrast where you've got this girl
who's obviously all she wants is just a
little bit of privacy when she gets
change that's all she wants and she's
still thinking about other people on the
other side and saying yeah you know I
know they want to be comfortable too but
I really just would like some privacy
that's her point meanwhile you've gotten
a day no concern whatsoever for the
feelings and rights of the girl that
school makes no mention of it he's just
celebrate yeah I got what I want not
everything I want but most of it he
makes no mention he doesn't even he
doesn't even not not even a an aside not
even a symbolic gesture to the other
side saying look I know that they feel
this way but hopefully we can work it
out if nothing none of that he does he
does not give a damn about them and
that's what I find it's like I said
yesterday you know I when you've got
these gender confused people I I think
that in a vacuum
generally speaking we want to be
compassionate towards people who suffer
from these sorts of confusions but when
you're just cruel and arrogant and
vicious
throwing other people's rights and
concerns to the side and trampling all
over them
and not giving a damn about them then my
sympathy for you is gone because now
you're just a bully
now you're just that's it and this is
what you find so often with trans
activists when it comes to these issues
they just don't care at all if people
are uncomfortable or if women want
privacy
they don't care it is all about them it
is not at all about the other side
because there are no concessions they
are willing to make it's just you know I
don't think we focus on this part of it
enough where we talk about the system
and everything and and and the wrong
policies and yeah we should be talking
about that but what about the individual
people who are demanding access to a
bathroom knowing that the people in that
room are uncomfortable and just want
privacy you know how about putting some
blame on them how about this mad a guy I
mean how about just some blame also on
his shoulders how about holding him
responsible for his own actions he's
being a bully
to put it mildly now okay so we talked
about all that I said the real question
is what do we do about this what do we
what do we do when this stuff happens in
the school how do we fight back
well the first thing we can do is is is
is remember that school boards the board
members are public officials and they
are setting policies that have a
profound impact on our children so if
you don't like a decision they made
they'll just complain about it into the
void I'll just scream into your pillow
don't just write angry tweets about it
give them your personal feedback and to
that end I'd recommend going to the
Township High School District 211
website a DC to a DC I tried to a DC dot
d 211 org a DC dot d 211 org go to that
website follow the links go to the
contact page page and you'll find the
public contact info for each of these
board members their email address the
you know number to reach them at the
office and I reach out to them and and
let them know how you feel
these again are public officials and
they are making decisions that have an
effect on the public on children they
don't have some right to do that without
hearing from the public but then
what if you're a parent and this happens
at your school what if you're a parent
at paletine or anywhere else where this
is happening and it's happening a lot of
places I don't think at this point yeah
you want to let give your feedback to
the school board but don't just do that
and call it a day other measures have to
be taken remember the school is putting
your daughter in jeopardy the school is
prioritizing the delusions and fantasies
of boys over the safety privacy peace of
mind and dignity of your daughter the
school is inviting dot the school is
inviting boys into the locker room to
watch your daughter get changed that's
what's happening so why is it this
happening in response why isn't every
parent in that school saying we are not
sending our daughters to class we are
not sending them into that building
until this policy has changed
we're not gonna send them you can come
arrest us if you want arrest us for
trying to protect our daughters go ahead
but we are not going to cooperate with
this why are parents doing that if every
parent did that if even half of the
parents did that this policy would
change overnight
you know with this stuff we as parents
have so much power we could put an end
to it immediately if we just use the
power that we have you just you you you
you have to force their hand so why not
why why not fight back like that this
policy was changed and in fact I've
heard from some kids at the school
talking about the environment in the
school after this policy was was decided
by the the school board and talking
about how you know there's tension
there's a lot of awkwardness people are
worried teachers some according to one
person wrote me he said that his
teachers anyway are basically you know
trying to shut down discussion of it but
my thing is why are there kids in that
school right now why is that school not
empty why is it not a ghost town five
hundred parents show up to the to the
school board meeting and and many of
them are against it good great for you
but then you send your kid to school the
next day why your whole point is that
you're putting your daughter in jeopardy
and you send her why give me one good
reason
I'm just so tired of this like if this
is happening the parents need to get
together and say we are not sending our
kids into that building I can tell you
this right now if it were me and I know
sometimes when people get into the if it
were me in this situation thing I don't
like it because it's easy for us to say
what we would do in that situation if
we're not in this situation but in this
one I can say very easily if that were
me and those worm that was my daughter
in that school there is no way in hell
she is going to school the next day
you want to come arrest me go ahead go
ahead and do it not but my daughter's
not stepping for stepping foot in that
in that school and like I said if every
parent did that or even half of the
parents did it
they would have to change the policy
they would have to you'd force their
hand they'd have to come up with a
different solution they would have no
choice
this was what teachers do teachers go on
strike when they don't like something
and then they get their way because you
need the teachers there well you need
the students there also it's the same
thing I say with the with the sports
stuff
you know you got these boys that come on
the track team or whatever
well what and then the boys come and
they steal all the medals and they ruin
everything and the other parents just
keep sending their daughters and why
aren't all the parents taking their kids
out of the sport and saying work no you
have made a mockery of this we are not
going to participate and and we're
certainly not doing fundraising and all
that stuff we're gone our money
everything is out our daughters are out
until you get these kids out of here and
so you make the school choose the school
has to choose between basically the end
of women's of girls sports in their
school or requiring that one or two
gender-confused boys stay where they
belong with the boys sports make them
choose that I just it's frustrating to
me
we have so much power that we don't use
were so concerned because at the end you
know this is why people talk about oh
we're headed for a civil war and stuff
in this culture and
that's not what I'm advocating here I'm
saying as I've said many times about
that people well people who worry that
we're headed for a civil war well we're
not because no one people are way too
lazy for that all anyone wants to do is
just complain about it on Twitter or you
know on Facebook or whatever to Penny
how old they are depending what
generation depends on what's what social
media site they go to to do their
complaining that's all anybody does
that's all anyone does that's it and
this is a perfect example I mean in this
case you know all you have to do is just
pull your kids out of the school it's a
really simple thing to do yeah it's
gonna be a little inconvenient
especially when you've got work and
everything and and yes I'm not
downplaying that but okay absorb the
inconvenience be inconvenienced this is
your kid we're talking about right is
your child
come on
step up just step up I don't wanna hear
any more complaints
I don't want to hear it like I don't
want to hear complaints about from
parents who willingly send their kids
into schools like this
I'll hear the pair I'll hear the
complaints from the kids
like the girl in that video no those are
complaints that I will that I want to
hear and that I think should be heard
and I'll sympathize there because those
kids don't have a choice
the parents have a choice though
so that's all palentine high school I'm
telling you right now you could stop
this by next week easily just stop
sending your kids that's all done done
okay let's leave it there we'll save I
got a bunch of emails we'll save those
for tomorrow but I think that's enough
for today
Godspeed the Matt Walsh show is produced
by Sean Hampton executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Donovan Fowler audio mixer Mike
Cora Mina the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 another day another impeachment
witness of firms the president Trump
committed no quid pro quo with Ukraine
of course you wouldn't know that from
the front pages of the New York Times in
the Washington Post we will parse the
spin and lies and then speaking of
spinning lies the Democrats return to
the stage for this month's presidential
primary debate high school girl cries
after her district forces her to undress
in front of boys and finally the mailbag
check it out on a Michael Noel's show
you